so my name is heat oh yeah I am working
with Angela's a scrip for for a year now
in two independent studies actually I
did - I am in the class of this
longfellows 18 I just graduated two
weeks ago
so when I came here to uh Sloan I was
interested and I was super focused on
working in intersection of government
technology innovation and
entrepreneurship when I when I started
doing my research I realized that there
was a super interest in a space that
it's about the stirrups doing working
selling to government to improve the
service delivery so my research my
independent study has been focused on
the space
so to narrow the topic of my independent
study I mean the key was the work that I
that I did with Anjali actually she
helped me a lot and when you come here
to the University you have a lot of
interest and everything is super broad
you want to do everything and you can't
in this kind of independent study so
having these kind of conversations every
week several hours per week will help me
a lot
so what I wanted to do in my independent
study was kind of combination of
research to see which was the academic
or or these these research parts already
made in the market in this market or in
this specific space but I also see and
take advantage of the connections that
you have here at MIT to see what was
going on in the market so with Anjali we
decided to create what we call public
tech at MIT series of speakers that it
was a good excuse for us to go out there
say you know okay I'm doing this
research I'm doing this line of research
about these needs and this thing but I
want to know what you are doing in this
space so please can you come here to MIT
explain us what you are doing and I mean
that was amazing I don't think that no
one is coming nowhere if you as a
student go but if you go and you say I'm
studying what you are doing here at MIT
they come so with these excuse we had
several people super level people doing
super interesting stuff that came here
to explain us what you were doing and
afterwards we had the opportunity of
course to take all that experience and
all that information to put it in our in
my case in my research paper and that
was amazing
here in this loan you come and suddenly
you have an entire ecosystem for you I
mean the challenge here is to understand
the ecosystem and to know where is your
tribe of people that interested in the
same things that you're interested in
and to be like super efficient with your
time because at the end of that you have
so many things to do so that combination
of good classes I mean like the state of
the art of many things in these classes
and the ecosystem on opportunities to do
and action learning and to her I mean to
to have this kind of interaction and
debates and conversations with people
that are already doing this kind of
things it's amazing I don't think that
you would have this in in many other
universities
what I learned many things during this
process especially because I was
interested in something super super
specifically specific and not
necessarily a very common in this in
this school so I was coming from the
public sector this is a business school
but still is a business and
administration school right so I mean
the stranger and you have also in the
government so what I what I had the
chance with this independent study it
was like focus on a specific
specifically this space that maybe I
didn't have too many chances or too many
opportunities to work on in other
classes or another in in other events or
whatever that they had in there in the
school
so a structure the work in an
independent study is kind of complicated
I think that it's like the most
challenging thing why because at the end
of the day you have a lot of classes
with a lot of homeworks and assignments
due to tomorrow or yesterday so I mean
when you have these independent studies
that you know that you have the whole
term to do it I mean you have always you
are always having other kind of
priorities so for me it was key to
create an outline from the beginning and
create a nice cut role for that outline
so at least I knew and I was tracking my
my performance and my development and
that's helped a lot I mean it's true
that at the end of the day you take this
last week that you have at the end of
the term to focus or to to create up to
edit or to to make it like the the
substantial thing of the independent
study but I think that I did a very good
work of job doing this all this research
and everything before the I would say
defer in the first part of the of the
term
talking about the challenges that I had
when working my independent study I
would say that maybe in my second
independent study that it was about as I
said before taking that case a real case
and used the research and the academic
content that i was a studying apply it
and see what could happened so i started
with let's say with an idea thinking
that that was the right thing to do and
that it could work in that it specific
context or a specific example there was
a study in peru and when i went through
all the research I was realizing that it
was not gonna work and that is super
complicated because it's a real case is
real people working and with a lot of
engagement and a lot of I mean ideas or
I know super positive about doing
something like that and I was seen like
I mean studying different cases studying
the researched own study know all the
information that I could get from the
MIT that that thing that they were twin
and I was a studying was not gonna work
so for me was kind of a struggling in
the process because I didn't want to
tell them that but I couldn't not do it
so I remember that I went through all
the process of writing everything and at
the end of the day at the end of the
process I said I need to put there my
recommendations and hard recommendations
like saying okay so there there are some
baselines that you are taking from
grounded there are not okay like blah
blah that's kind of things that it was
kind of and I had a conversation with
them it was hard but I mean you can see
their their real value of the
independent study and the process that
you are doing right at least I guess
that if I don't think that they are
doing any more dispray because the
conversation that we had because the
research that I did and that that has
value but it was hard